Nelson Mandela's grandson dances his way
through the crowd despite the sadness
the outpouring of sympathy is a source
of great comfort to his family for days
people have come to Mandela's house in
Johannesburg here and throughout the
country they want to show what Mandela
meant to them in the township of Soweto
where the struggle against apartheid
began people from around the world have
been paying their respects we need to
take this opportunity to somehow express
our respect our gratitude are no words
possible to describe what we did
commemoration in Cape Town the seat of
parliament deputy's sing for the first
black president of south africa in
remembrance of his message of
reconciliation as a global figure Nelson
Mandela's vision transcended the
physical borders of our country it
permeated the fabric of global society
and is as two of our nation as it is of
the entire world the main memorial is
set to take place in this football
stadium in johannesburg on tuesday it's
a place with special meaning it was here
that Mandela made his last official
appearance at the soccer world cup in
2010 10 years earlier he gave a speech
here for democracy their freedom fighter
is dead but many South Africans swear
they will carry on Nelson Mandela's
legacy